pour commencer il faut revenir sur le
meurtre du petit philippe bertrand
la colère et l'indignation sont loin
d'avoir disparu à 3 ou demain doivent
avoir lieu les obsèques du jeune garçon
dans sa cellule de la prison de chaumont
patrick henry qui pour l'instant n'est
inculpé que d'enlèvement d'enfants n'a
toujours rien avoué je ne parlerai qu'en
présence de mes avocats avait-il dit
quand les policiers l'ont arrêté or pour
l'instant aucun avocat ne veut défendre
le meurtrier présumé du petit philippe
par exemple ce soir le bâtonnier bremner
du barreau de l'aube a refusé lui aussi
l'instruction sera accélérée disait hier
monsieur lecanu est accélérée n'est pas
expéditive a ajouté aujourd'hui le
ministre de la justice la justice
précisément c'est elle qui va maintenant
intervenir
c'est elle qui doit nous rappeler que
quel que soit le sentiment que l'on
éprouve dans ce genre d'affaires il faut
que la sérénité pour juger ce qui ne
vaut pas ce que j'espérais steve et il
faut pas non plus que l'on choisisse le
genre d'affaires pour lequel cette
justice s'appliquerait pas su s'y plier
tlj je n'irai même pas une justice
rapide car le mot rapide laisserait
penser qu' il va y avoir une justice
lente mais une justice qui s'en tiennent
à l'essentiel et qui dans des délais
raisonnables puisse amener l'inculpé à
répondre aux deux champions quand on dit
que la justice doit passer rude et vite
à votre avis c'est une erreur il faut
qu'elle soit sereine il faut qu'elle
soit sereine
il faut que fonctionnel mais peut-être
mais peut-être
sereine tout en étant rude ça c'est une
question d'appréciation je n'aimais pas
la place qui devrait surtout c'est que
c'est que tous journalistes citoyens
nous pensions qu'il ya des hommes qui ne
savaient pas que ce sont eux qui sont
choisis dans quelques mois par tirage au
sort pour juger un criminel qui a commis
un crime particulièrement horrible bien
et c'est ces gens là qui sont parmi nous
que nous pouvons rencontrer demain dans
la rue sur les routes
eh bien ces sommes doivent être à l'abri
justement de ce que j'appelais tout à
l'heure cette sorte de matraquage de
l'opinion publique cette mise en
condition de l'opinion publique il faut
que ce soit en toute liberté qui seront
c'est que quelle que soit la décision
nous accueillons tous devant la justice
du jury français